جزيلا لك ايمان اذا نرحب بكم مشاهدينا في
هذه الفقره للتحليل العسكري لمجريات حرب
اسرائيل على قطاع غزه معنا كالعاده المحلل
العسكري لواء فايز الدويري وايضا معنا
الزميل محمود الكن الذي يرافقنا بالخريطه
التفاعليه تفضل نعم ابرز ما يحدث الان
مياده خلال فتره هذه الهدنه هي الامور
التكتيكيه مستوى عملياتي هنا بالنسبه
للقوات قوات الاحتلال المنتشره كانت في
قطاع غزه كنا دوما نتحدث عن التوغل في
قطاع غزه لكن شاهدنا يوم امس نقطه التسليم
كانت هنا في ميدان فلسطين وهي نقطه كان
التوغل الاسرائيلي قد وصل اليها لذلك من
المهم ان نميز بين السيطره والتوغل في هذه
الحالات وكنا قد ذكرناه سابقا اليوم الصور
التي حضرت كانت من ميناء غزه وهو ضمن نقاط
التوغل الاسرائيلي لكن لم تظهر الصور وجود
القوات الاسرائيليه هناك في الحقيقه هناك
اعاده تموضع بحسب المصادر الى مناطق هنا
غرب شارع الرشيد بالتالي استخدام السواتر
الترابيه كما اظهرت صور الاقمار الصناعيه
سابقا هذا الامر حدث كذلك هنا بالقرب من
مستشفى الرنتيسي في الشمال اعاده تموضع
للقوات اعاده تموضع في المناطق المفتوحه
التي يمكن للقوات ا التجمع وحمايه نفسها
من اي ا اطلاق ناري في المستقبل بالطبع
سيكون هناك المزيد من هذا التحليل مع
اللواء فايز دويري ومياده لاحقا لكن دعونا
ننتقل الى هذا الحدث الذي ظهر اليوم هنا
في خليج عدن في هذه النقطه كان هناك يبدو
انهما حدثان منفصلان مهاجمه من قبل اي ما
وصفوا
بالقراصنة
منسوبه الى سفينه تجاريه مملوكه اسرائيليا
بحسب البيانات
لكن الحدث الاخر الذي تم كذلك في ذات
الوقت هو اطلاق صواريخ بالستيه من هنا من
مناطق سيطره انصار الله الحوثي باتجاه
المدمره الامريكيه التي كانت متواجده هناك
يو اس اس ميسن لكن ام
ال الذي اطلق هو صاروخ بيستي الصواريخ
الباليستيه ليست مصممه لاهداف متحركه او
على الاقل في البحر لماذا الصواريخ ال
يعني معظم الخبراء يشيرون ان الصواريخ
التي يمتلكها انصار الله الحوثي جماعه
انصار الله الحوثي هي من النوع البالستي
سكت سي مطوره من ذلك الوقت بالتالي
الصاروخ البالستي لا يعمل مثل صواريخ كروز
هو يعمل بالدفع ثلاث مراحل مرحله الدفع
اولا هذه هي المرحله هنا تكون محرك يكون
محرك الصاروخ قد انطلق ويدا جهاز التوجيه
بالعمل في هذه المرحله لانه يقوم بتحريك
المحرك الدافع الى الاتجاه المطلوب او
الذي تقوم الحسابات وتعتقد انه الاتجاه
الصحيح هنا تبدا مرحله الطيران مرحله
الطيران تقوم
بالانطلاق خارج الغلاف الجوي ومن ثم اعاده
الدخول الى الغلاف الجوي والدخول بسرعه
كبيره الى الهدف الهدف يكون عاده مساحيا
كبير
وبالتالي قالت القوات الامريكيه انه كان
بعيدا عن نقطه الاستهداف حوالي 18 كترا
لكن ما هي المدمره وكيف تم الاستهداف
ولماذا هذا سيكون مزيد معكم من التفاصيل
مياده واللواء فايز دويري شكرا محمود اذا
المزيد حول هذه المدمره يو اس اس ميسن ما
الذي تملكه من
قدرات ما طبيعه عمل هذه السفينه نشاهدها
الان اذا امامنا اذا هذه هي سفينه المدمره
التي تتبع اسطول او مجموعه يو اس اس ايزن
هاور التي تتواجد في منطقه الخليج خليج
عدن تحديدا حدثنا اذا لواء فايز عن هذه
المدمره وما تملكه من قدرات وطبيعه عملها
يعني الان تقريبا هناك عده اساطيل امريكيه
بدءا من الاسطول الخامس المتواجد في
الخليج العربي مقره في المنامه والاسطول
السادس البحر المتوسط موجود قيادته في
نابولي و ال الاسطول القوه الضاربه
الرئيسي الاسطول السابع وهناك اي في كل
اسطول في بعض الحالات مجموعات قتال
ومجموعات القتال
اي مختلفه حسب التشكيل من منطقه الى منطقه
لكن القوام الرئيسي لها كون عاده حامله
الطائرات وحتى حاملات الطائرات مختلفه من
حيث الكفاءه والقدره وعدد الطائرات معها
مجموعه من السفن المدمرات الفرقاطات
الغواصات سفن الامداد سفن التزويد الى غير
ذلك تتحرك كمجموعه هذه الان عندما نتحدث
عن مدمره يو اس اس لديها قدرات هذه تقريبا
حتى متباينه حسب انواع المدمرات شاءت
الظروف ان
اي نشاهدها عن قرب وندخل لها وبالتالي هذه
تمتلك اولا منظومه دفاع جوي شبه متكامله
ضد الصواريخ
و كذلك لديها صواريخ توماهوك يوجد فيها
صواريخ ضد السفن وضد هذه ولديها صواريخ
موجهه ضد الرادارات اذا هي منظومه عمل
عمليات متكامله احد واجباتها حمايه حامله
الطائرات من اي هجوم صاروخي لانها تكون
منتشره بزوايا واتجاهات معينه حول حامله
حامله الطائرات وهي ال الجسم الرئيسي في
مجموعه القتال الان هذه كانت موجوده في
البحر الاحمر اي في خليج عدن التقاء البحر
الاحمر مع بحر عمان وبالتالي كان هناك
حادث قرصني في البدايه كان الاعتقاد انه
قد يكون يمنيين تبين لاحقا انهم من
القراصنه الصوماليين لكن الغريب في الامر
ان تزامن العمل هذا مع هذا العمل لا اقول
انه مرتبط به بقدر ما هو متزامن الان
اطلاق صواريخ كما تحدث محمود صواريخ
بالستيه هذه موجهه اصلا الى مناطق يتم
برمجتها وتتحرك باليه كما تحدث محمود طيب
وبالتالي لا يمكن ان ان ان ترسل الى الا
اذا كان الهدف سياسي او الهدف باننا
موجودين وقد نطور ذلك من الصواريخ
البالستيه غير الفاعله لهذه الاهداف الى
صواريخ موجهه مجنحه الان هذه المدمره بكل
الامكانيات التي تحدث عنها لواء فايز لم
ترصد الصواريخ
البالستيه وايضا بقيه الاسطول المتواجد في
المنطقه وما حدث ان هذه الصواريخ اخطات
هدفها نظرا للاسباب التي ذكرتها وذكرها م
يعني الان انا الصواريخ ت تخطئ امر متوقع
غير المتوقع ان هذه الان هل هي موجوده
لواحدها هل هي ضمن تتحرك ضمن مجموعه
القتال هل لديها قطع بحريه تساندها لكن
السؤال هذه مزوده برادار فاعله تغطي
مسافات كبيره جدا كيف تم
اي اطلاق هذه الصواريخ ولم يتم اسقاطها هل
كانت مفاجاه لانه العمل غير متقع هل كان
اطقم العمل ليسوا في جاهزيه كبيره لكن هذا
التاريخ علمنا ان منظومات الرادار يمكن
اختراقها هبطت طائرات داخل ساحه الكريملين
طائرات الشراعيه فبالتالي الاختراق وارد
لكن هذه ثغره واضحه في الاختراق وارد
لاسباب تقنيه تتعلق بمنظومه الرادار
الخاصه بهذه السفينه قد تكون اخطاء بشريه
انا اقول ان الخطا بشري اكثر منه تقني
لانه قدراتها من حيث الكشف رصد الاه داف
والتعامل مع لديها منظومات دفاع جوي
مختلفه لكن المشكله انه لم يتم رص رصد
الصواريخ عدم الرصد ليس تقني عدم الرصد قد
يكون خطا بشري وبالتالي هذه لابد انه اكيد
سيعمل على معالجتها وطوال فتره انطلاق
الصاروخ البالستي لم يتم رصده وبالتالي لم
يتم اطلاق اي صاروخ اعتراضي من قبل هذه
المدمره او من بقيه الا اعتراضه لا من هذه
القطعه البحريه ولا من غيرها من القطعه
البحريه اذا هو في الاصل لم يتم رصده لو
تم رصده لتمت اعتراضه لكن ليس كيف لم يتم
رصده ارجح الخطا البشري اكثر من الخطا
التقني ا طيب ل نحرك السفينه مره اخرى نحو
البحر في خليج عدن
وتحديدا المنطقه التي حدث فيها بدايه
القرصنه التي وفق البنتاجون واللواء رايدر
وقتها كان قد اشار انهم يرجحون سيناريو ان
يكون قراصنه صوماليون وفق ذكرهم هم من
قاموا بالنزول على هذه السفينه بالتزامن
مع اطلاق الصواريخ البلسيه من قبل
الحوثييين نريد ايضا نفهم تواجد الاسطول
هنا هو الاسطول الذي يتواجد هنا الاسطول
الخامس هذه مبدئيا هي تابعه لمجموعه ايزن
هور مجموعه ايزن هور ذهبت الى الخليج
العربي والخليج العربي مقر الاسطور الخامس
في المنامه في البحرين فيفترض ان تكون
تابعه هذه يمكن ان تتغير يعني دعينا نقول
هذه المجموعات الحربيه المرافقه لحامله
الطائرات قد يتم تبديلها لظروف اي موضوعيه
او ظروف تقنيه او ما شابه ذلك لكن حتى
تنظيم المجموعه البحريه ال المرافقه
لحامله الطائرات لا يوجد في الكتب في كتب
الاف ام الامريكيه تنظيم ثابت اذا ذهبنا
الى مقارنه الاساطيل نفسها لا يوجد مقارنه
ما بين قدرات الاسطول الخامس مع الاسطول
السابع الاسطول السابع يعتبر القوه
الضاربه في البحريه الامريكيه قوته تعادل
اكثر من الاسطول الخامس والسادس مجتمعين
وبالتالي حتى حاملات الطائرات قد تنقل من
اسطول الى اسطول حسب ظروف المعركه استدر
ان كان لدينا بقيه وقت للانتقال الى موضوع
اخر لننتقل الى جزئيه تتعلق
ب هناك قائد سريه ونائب قائد سريه تم
فصلهما بناء على قرار اخذ في الميدان
نتيجه الاشتباكات مع حماس وكتائب القسام
تحديدا وكان القرار هو بسحب هذ سريه كامله
من المعركه وهذا ما ادى لقرار الفصل ما
الدلالات وراء ذلك الدلالات انه رغم هو
كانت الحجه عدم تقديم غطاء ناري وهذا
الحجه انا منجه نظري كمتابع هي مثيره
للسخريه هذا الغطاء الناري الذي قدم له لو
قدم ل القسام 1200 مقاتل النخبه صباح
السابع من اكتوبر ساعيد ما قلته سابقا في
المقاربه السابقه لاستطاعوا الوصول الى تل
الابي والقدس لو قدم لهم هذا على
امكاناتهم متواضعه ما قدم لهم ي يعني ما
قدم في هذا القاطع وحده قد يعادل ما يقدم
الى فرقه في الهجوم رغم ذلك لانه هو اصلا
جبان وبالتالي هذه عقده لدى الجيش
الاحتلال اذا كان متفوقا في المعركه فهو
اسد واذا تكاف وواجه خصم وند
قوي يخلع رداء الاسد ويصبح برداء اخر لا
اود استخدام المفرد وبالتالي هو هرب ج انا
اعتبر ان خرو اتوقع ان القياده
الاسرائيليه اعتبرت هذا الضابط ومساعده
جبناء وبالتالي قاموا بسحب السريه ليس
لحقوا الضرر بالسريه رغم ما قيل حول
الخلافات لكن الحق الضرر بالوحده الام
الكتيبه لانه هذا هجوم كتيبه الهجوم سيكون
هناك وحده على يمينه وحده على يساره او
على الاقل قد يكون هو وحده جانبيه وهناك
وحده اخرى في احد الاتجاهات عندما ينسحب
يخلق منطقه فراغ جغرافيه فبالتالي تؤدي
الى
فشل العمليه للوحده الاكبر فلهذا السبب
لواء فايز مع كل يوم يتكشف المزيد حول ما
يجري من عمليات بريه وواقع الامر الذي لا
نشاهده ولكن تفيدنا كل الفيديوهات التي
تصدر عن الاعلام العسكري لحماس وكذلك بعض
المعلومات التي تتوفر عبر الاقمار
الصناعيه عن ما يجري في الميدان ولكن هكذا
معلومات تعطي كما ذكرت دلالات ابعد من ذلك
انه بالفعل بدايه ليست السيطره كما التوغل
وكذلك لا يعني كل هذا الغطاء الجوي ان
الجنود قادرون على الثبات امام المقاومه
من ضمن ايضا المعلومات التي تسربت وفق
الاعلام الاسرائيلي هي الجزئيه الخاصه
بلقاء
السنوار رئيس الحركه في قطاع غزه للاسرى
في احد الانفاق يعني هذه رساله بمنتهى
الذكاء والفطنه رساله من قائد متمرس انا ه
لا امدحه رغم انه يستحق لكن اقول هذا
العمل هذا الاجراء بمنتهى طيب